halthier rage chef de bureau du à fos
ottawa josée legault michel serrault
gibbons soir j'hésitais avant de placer
la nouvelle tout à l'heure en une de
l'émission des élections précipitées
peut-être avant je veux dire est ce
qu'on joue jument même temps on n'est
pas de 20 personnes et il ya
théoriquement cette possibilité là il ya
un bras de fer en tout cas l'un portant
sur la création d'un comité a le tirage
est ce que vous pensez que le npd va
apaiser touche à demain il va voter que
le gouvernement et je crois que oui mais
je pense qu'il va y avoir une bonne
raison pour encore rappeler libéraux ils
disent encore ce soir qu' il croit que
c'est une bureau devait admettre que
c'est pas vraiment un vote de confiance
on ne peut pas vraiment besoin des
élections le perthus on croire que
libéraux veulent avoir des élections
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
entreprises ont mis cette motion comme
un vote de confiance
mais c'est à voir ici une belle peau
avoir la tête dans la poche des libéraux
puis il s'inquiète que c'est la
perception qui semble se développer
bon alors oui ça va être celle là
josée legault pour ça que on n'y croit
pas vraiment mais en même temps
admettons que cette nuit ce soit en
retard mais ceci dit ça suffit
j'en ai marre
alors ben écoutez on n'a pas loin de
mettre d'accord vous y croyez pas
demandez
et c'est parce que blague à part le
leadership de monsieur jack meeting le
chef du npd bram est vraiment faible
depuis longtemps et ça se et ça se
poursuit et tout ça moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que tout ça c'est que
c'est comme un très mauvais spectacle on
a plein de pandémie quand même mondial
et on a au parlement fédéral des petites
joutes partisanes et politique qui se
joue et ça rigole de part et d'autre et
c est ça fait willocq il y en aura pas
d'élection c'est bien je trouve que ça
manque quand même peu de sérieux et pour
dire un cliché mais ça fait partie de ce
qui alimente aussi le cynisme dans la
population
monsieur singh s'est très bien j'imagine
que c'est très bien que son parti n'est
pas équipé pour partir en sélection il
sera pas de toute manière au printemps
il ne sera peut-être pas pâques
européens notre cher mais le nom le
spectacle de mauvais goût que de jouer
cette comédie collective michel 6 oui
mais dans les parlements des accidents
ça arrive
de cette façon là c'était la première
guerre mondiale personne n'en voulait
m'est arrivé pareil il faut faire
attention et il faut dire que monsieur
rodriguez les libéraux ont monté la des
enchères est au coeur parce que ça fait
un peu partie de bluff aussi évoqué sa
chair en 10 à 7 une motion de confiance
ce qui n'était pas nécessaire voilà et
ça fait penser que peut-être que les
libéraux allierait pour ça sans aller en
élections il voit ce qui est arrivé à
monsieur monsieur réexamen au nouveau
brunswick à main c'est ce qui est en
train d'arriver à monsieur reviennent en
colombie britannique dans une situation
de pandémie d'habitude ses joues pour le
gouvernement des gens disant ne pas
changer spalter alors est-ce que ça
attentes aux libéraux de
d'aller en élections peut-être bien vous
savez ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous
en début d'émission explique avec le web
loin c'est que l'opposition veut créer
un comité qui auraient des pouvoirs
quand même assez élargi pour examiner la
sphère oui charity en troll aurait des
pouvoirs pour faire venir des
fonctionnaires s'expliquer la
documentation
le gouvernement dit on est d'accord pour
un comité mais pas du tout ce type là
alors c'est ça l'objet de la chicane et
là le gouvernement a ajouté qu on vous
avait dit michel ici vous nous forcez
avoir votre comité qu'on juge exagérée
abus de pouvoir dit pablo à google mais
effectivement on considère que ce sera
un vote de confiance perdue et kyron
campagne électorale je fais écouter
quelques extraits aujourd'hui parce que
pour les conservateurs pour le bloc
c'est clair ils vont voter pour la
création de ce comité
les scandales de ce gouvernement brise
la confiance des citoyens
quand est ce que le premier ministre a
arrêté de gouverner pour ses amis et
commencer à gouverner pour tous les
canadiens
on arrête tout de niaiser en même temps
on a d'autres choses à faire le premier
ministre vêtue où veux tu peux aller en
élection de socothyd la chambre monsieur
le président nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied pour livrer pour les
canadiens et nous allons continuer de le
faire
en espérant que les partis d'opposition
vont continuer à travailler pour faire
fonctionner ce parlement minoritaire
on est tellement près de réaliser une
solution donc ce qui est clair pour moi
c'est peut-être le premier ministre ne
veut pas arriver à une solution il veut
selon trouver une excuse de plonger le
pays dans une élection mais tant qu a
finalement voté que le gouvernement
haïtien dernier tour de table là dessus
pour comme ceux ci n'y a pas à avaler
aujourd'hui la pilule entre bons vins
très bien nous on va tout faire pour que
qui a pas d'élection n'est ce pas ça qui
a dit la cultive un peu plus le mystère
est encore entraîné côté alors qu'il
veut pas lui d'un explique à l'étude
ils ont déjà négocié avec des
comparateurs qu'ils ont changé qualité
qu'ils ont fait à claire dans la motion
que ce n'est pas une motion de confiance
mais je dirais que pourquoi pas
d'aujourd'hui le npd c'est vraiment
comme le seul adulte à la pâte pour
l'instant vraiment une motion suis très
partisane comparateur c'est une réponse
ultra partisans sa fille véra puis le
npd est en fait coincer adam le jeu et
déjoue c'est de dire qu'on est là pour
vous voyez on est à peine présenté et
les nouvelles lois des programmes
sociaux pour aider les gens bon mais là
il semble qu'ils sont encore en train de
négocier quelque chose
qu'est ce que ça va donner dans les
prochaines 12 heures je le sais pas mais
je ne dirais pas que c'est parce que
c'est la course de tau npd il ya
quelqu'un qui passe on s'était vraiment
aux conservateurs libéraux ouais c'est
ça se passe c'est que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai dit que tous les partis
jouent leur jeu partisane en ce moment
justement et que le npd c'est peut-être
le plus mal équipées yobo et radio
qu'elle est quand même très mal équipé
peut pas partir en élections mais très
franchement on ce qu'on voit aussi en
effet c est menée autour du nouveau chef
conservateur qui veut se faire les dents
mais encore une fois le sait c'est bon
les élections dans une province mais là
c'est un pays en n'étant pas des
milliers savaient pas très sérieux ok
l'université d'ottawa on y revient je
vous faire entendre aujourd'hui des
extraits qui sont arrivées de la classe
politique à québec mais vous allez
réécouter à la toute fin
monsieur singh ou si qu'un avis
contraire en écoute les universités
doivent être des endroits où on peut
faire des débats où la liberté
d'expression est important que ce soit à
concordia où que ce soit ce qui se passe
actuellement tahoua
goethe un dérapage important qui est
inquiétant qui est inquiétant le c'est
comme si on avait une espèce de police
de la censure en plus d'accuser les
francophones moi j'ai beaucoup de misère
etc sol
je crois que c'est une dérive que de
vouloir l'écarter complètement il faut
être capable de reconnaître aussi qu'il
ya eu des événements déplorables
racistes sont aux campus universitaire
et qu'on soit capable de les qualifier
qu'on soit capable aussi de dire des
choses quand on parle de racisme
systémique c'est de ça aussi dont il
s'agît qu'on soit capable de dire les
mots si tout le monde est capable de
s'exprimer à ce sujet loupé de parler
franc jeu je pense comme société on va
sortir gagnant
on peut pas s'empêcher collectivement de
réfléchir sur des sujets parce qu'ils
ont une charge historique si on veut
apprendre de nos erreurs en occident on
peut pas brûler nos livres ou tasses et
nous livre parce qu'ils sont
inconfortables
c'est tellement clair qu'un professeur
ne doit pas utiliser un mot comme ça qui
est chargée qui est plein d des racismes
historique qui peuvent blesser les
autres tout le monde sont d'accord je
crois que c'est complètement
inacceptable ce que la fille pts bon
mais non tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord parce que justement on viens de
l'entendre avant monsieur 5 dit c'est
inacceptable et celle ci aux juges
commencent avec vous bon cette histoire
n'est pas terminée monsieur frémont dans
sa lettre hier finalement relancé la
controverse il lancé plutôt que de
l'apaiser ça c'est certain
il ya deux choses qui sont clairs d'une
part la perception de la liberté
académique versus l'utilisation de ce
mot là où d'autres mots controversé
n'est vraiment pas la même au québec et
dans le reste du pays sauf une chose la
liberté académique ici puis c'est une
valeur qui a peut-être plus d'importance
que qu'ailleurs cela sur une différence
de vue d'autre part faut pas tout
mélanger dans cette histoire là il ya ce
qui s'est passé à l'université de troyes
les insultes racistes contre les
francophones avec le mot af cette fois
ci ça cette arrivée sur twitter
faut quand même pas tout mélanger
mais comme d'habitude ça a permis à une
coupe de déjà qui fonctionne sous des
noms d'emprunt sur twitter elle tient à
michel dit sur les campus anglophone
verser de tabasser c'est à la frontière
entre les deux mondes si je peux le dire
la réaction est pas la même quelle est
votre perception de ce débat là qui
court depuis jeudi dernier depuis qu'on
a su que cette enseignante avait été
suspendu pour avoir utilisé dans un
cadre académique le mot à n ouais c'est
vrai je suis pas certaine que vraiment
une grande percée entre les campus au
québec et le campus dans le reste du
canada
je pense que beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
d'accord avec ce que mr sting avis mais
quand même d'une certaine ironie que
dans une place où on de presse
questionné sur le site datant de ce mot
là les étudiants qui n'étaient pas
portable vous ne sentez pas assez
confortable pour qu'elles se lier la
professeure à son utilisation de ce
moulin puis je pense que c'est
décourageant en partie ce mot ne devrait
pas être utilisé pour blaise ni
quiconque mais c'est aussi pouvoir avoir
ce sens et je sentais ce sens est libre
se sentir capable de s'exprimer de ce
qu'on reçoit caen se mourait est
utilisée qui était si je comprends bien
à la base de ce cours comme tel mais
comptera que tout à fat albert d'ottawa
mais on n'en parle pas vraiment parler
entre autant parler dans les médias en
ontario même dans les médias ici à
ottawa s'attend pas vraiment fureur au
québec et qui paye quoi bon mais mais
pourquoi elle tient jeu rapidement
pourquoi selon vous pourquoi on a parle
pas plus parce que là la réponse allait
susciter beaucoup plus de réactions au
québec et dans la communauté francophone
et puis sur le campus de liberté comme
le respect ou campus de l'illberg
atahualpa vraiment il fallait aller peut
capter une autre foire devient
anglophone alors une histoire qu'est ce
que tu fais passer sensibilité sans
différence c'est comme si l'acceptation
de ne pas prononcer ce mot en anglais
était plus et l'acceptation est
davantage présente à l'est sont les
cruches et ailleurs c'est comme si on
avait accepté qu'on oublie t rès
homologue peu importe le cadre mais là
je pense pas que ça a été accepté
quand même une lettre ouverte de près de
600 professeurs en appui à l'enseignante
qui d'après tout ce qu'on a c'est en
effet ne pas utiliser ce mot là de
manière raciste mais dedans vraiment
dans le cadre d'une démonstration de
nature pédagogique et historique
moi je pense que si
des étudiants qui n'ont pas voulu en
discuter avec elle malgré le fait
qu'elle a invités à les inviter à le
faire c'est justement parce que on est
dans une atmosphère de plus en plus
polarisé
et là je dirais que dominique anglade la
chef du plq elle a vraiment marqué le
pas elle est sortie tout de suite ce
matin et elle a soulevé cette question
là justement et 7 polarisait cette
polarisation aulaqi qui domine de plus
en plus non seulement dans les campus
universitaires la vallée des baux public
en général ça fait que justement les
échanges les dialogues ne sont plus
possibles
vous avez quand vous avez un cas de bons
points 4 de méchant ça dépasse il vous
faut considérer bons ou méchants et
c'est un père changeable je pense qu
est-ce que choqué beaucoup c'est
l'attitude du recteur jacques frémont
qui ne s'est pas non seulement ne s'est
pas porté à la défense de la liberté
académique de son enseigne qu'il avait
fait absolument priés de mal mais il l'a
carrément jeté en pâture à ses critiques
et je pense que monsieur vraiment pas
son choix
c'était son choix la pile à temps pour
aller et je pense que monsieur frémont
ne semble pas comprendre cet honneur
pour l ancien président de commission
des droits de la personne que nous ne
vivons plus dans le monde prie médias
sociaux lorsqu'on lorsqu'on envoie
quelqu'un comme ça en pâture eh bien il
se passe des choses très très très très
laide sur les médias sociaux et donc du
harcèlement elle a eu du harcèlement
d'intimidation on a donné son long de
donner son numéro de téléphone
donc on me met sa sécurité personnelle
en danger il faut lire son entrevue ce
matin avec qu'ils avaient lâché dans la
presse qui était la journaliste qui
avait sorti d'histoire la semaine
dernière moi je trouve toute cette
histoire là très laide et j'espère qu'il
y aura au québec au moins des paramètres
qui vont beaucoup mieux protéger la
liberté académique dans quel camp il ya
des plaintes parce qu'il peut y avoir
des plaintes
michel elle tient un joli moment des
plaintes d'étudiants légitime bien sûr
il faut qu'un processus
on a cette personne n'ose le professeur
loeb n'a pas été perdue n'a pas eu tâche
néanmoins de vue et ça c'est un principe
de justice naturelle
même si au delà du débat actuel
c'est quand même incroyable qu'elles
doivent se défendre par les médias est
imposé ouais mais ils devraient je crois
qu'il y en ait la liberté de ton merci à
vous trois données leblanc je m'excuse
on va se parler notre foi sur la
nomination des juges et notre collègue
nora sorti un texte fort intéressant à
ce que est ce qu'on a encore des
problèmes parce que s'il faut être rouge
avec un gouvernement rouge puis blain
qu'un gouvernement bleu prénommé juge
on va parler daniel je suis beau [ __ ]
de melilla [ __ ] faut que j'aille merci
bonsoir
au revoir merci au revoir